was hast du gerade zu mir gesagt ich bin
noch nicht behindert warum sagst du zu
mir nicht mehr behindert ich lege sehr
viel Wert darauf dass ich am
Muttersöhnchen bin mein ganzer
Freundeskreis finde ich mich bescheuert
so ich denke mal so ich bin auch so ein
Prototyp so von vom neuen deutschen auch
oder auch vielleicht auch vom neuen
Politiker
Spiele so ich liebe das Spiel so wie es
ist ja so wie du deine Freundin liebst
und die hat auch manchmal Mundgeruch
oder hat auch irgendwie mal Scheiße
geschminkt ich ich bin einfach Fan ich
bin richtig krasser Fan davon
ich kann auch explizit wirklich auch
Schimpfwörter verzichten
bin auch das Hochdeutsch ist mächtig und
ich kenne doch den Unterschied zwischen
Genitiv und Dativ
in einem gewissen Maße ist auf jeden
Fall auch korrekt und überlebt das
Geschäft
bist du wirklich kriminell hast du schon
mal was geklaut ja was heißt bist du
wirklich kriminell also ich habe geklaut
und ich habe auch schon mal Sachen
gemacht die verboten sind ich war beim
Verkehrspsychologen
schon mal gemacht so ich habe Interviews
abgesagt und deswegen kann ich einfach
wenn es hart auf hart kommt drei Tage
fünf Tage oder auch zehn Tage am Stück
spielen so ich muss mich manchmal
zwingen nicht zu spielen mit einem
gewissen Alter habe ich keinen Bock mehr
auf rappen und Bravo Cover ich will halt
noch ein paar Jahre Halligalli machen
und irgendwann ist dann noch Ende
Gelände dann mache ich Familie mit mit
hoffentlich vielen Kindern und meiner
Traumfrau und wenn ich das auch
irgendwann geschafft habe weil ich
nichts mehr zu tun habe so dann habe ich
mir überlegt ob ich erstmal
Bürgermeister von Berlin werde
und wenn ich das geschafft habe dann
keine Ahnung dann muss man gucken was
ich alles machen muss entweder
Bundespräsident oder Bundeskanzler oder
so ich meine solange ich nicht an Größen
waren erkranke ist das für mich doch
eine auf jeden Fall eine Alternative